uh matthew taylor thanks for talking to
us um tell us a little bit more about
how you make that link between energy
prices and health
so there's a clear link between people
being cold
and their susceptibility to illness
indeed the government's own vaccines
minister just a few days ago recognized
that when people are cold
they are more susceptible to flu other
viruses respiratory illnesses as well
and so
research suggests even an ordinary year
around ten thousand people additionally
die as a consequence of cold
now that challenge
could be massively worse uh this winter
because of this unprecedented potential
rising energy bills
and it's our responsibility as health
leaders to point out that for a health
system which is already finding it
incredibly difficult to deal with the
demand that we face we are working flat
out in the health service but we face
unprecedented demand going into a winter
that looks like it's going to be very
tough if we add into that
more people who are unable to heat their
homes
we'll also see more people getting sick
and we'll see more demand and that is
going to be a problem for the health
service for all of us who use the health
service
yes and i want to hear what you're
calling for in a moment but but tell me
a little bit more about some of the
risks you mentioned respiratory
illnesses are there other risks as well
that are health related i mean what
about mental health as well does that
have an impact on on people's mental
health too
yes absolutely
we know there is a correlation between
poverty and ill health and you're
absolutely right honor to say that
that's physical health but also mental
health and
amongst the other challenges we face in
health service we see major backlogs for
access to mental health services so
greater poverty drives more demand for
health services more people being sick
but but but
fuel poverty people not being able to
eat homes is a particularly kind of
pernicious
form of poverty and particularly effect
directly drives
a people's greater susceptibility to
illness and their greater need to use
the health service so that we absolutely
recognize the government faces some
unenviable choices given the pressures
on our economy and on public spending
right now
but it is our job in the health service
to be clear about the fact that
the enormous challenges we have today in
august in meeting demand are going to be
tougher in the winter and they're going
to be even tougher if we have got
thousands hundreds of thousands or
millions of people who feel unable to
eat their homes
so what
can the government do they would say
they already have plans in action
they're talking about this 400 pounds
for every household towards their energy
bills they're promising
more support for the more vulnerable
people plus the two leadership
candidates have plans of their own so so
what are you calling for
so it isn't up to us to tell the
government what to do about energy bills
or tax policy or benefit policy
those are choices for the chancellor and
the government but it is our
responsibility to be clear about the
consequences of the situation we're in
and we're speaking on behalf of nhs
leaders and those leaders are telling us
that they were already seeing
effects in their communities as a
consequence of the cost of living crisis
uh they are already many many nhs
leaders having to deal with their own
low paid staff needing help because they
can't make ends meet and that's in
hospitals and community services
right across the health service and that
is in august and so
what our leaders have said to us is that
we need to highlight the fact that if
this situation deteriorates as it could
do if the gap the affordability gap when
it comes to fuel bills increases over
winter
then those challenges will be greater
and you know you have quite rightly been
reporting on
on on your bulletins over the last few
weeks people waiting for ambulances
ambulances queuing up outside accident
emergency departments this is
fundamentally added because of a gap
between the demand on the health service
and the capacity that we've got
and whilst i will often come on your
program and talk about capacity issues
how do we get more staff how do we
invest more in capital we also have to
talk about the things that demand that
drive demand for health services
and more people being cold in the winter
will drive more demand and that will
mean that that that demand capacity
problem will become worse
well yes and the nhs of course has been
under unprecedented pressure over the
last couple of years because of the
covid crisis are you saying this could
be as bad
well you know kovid
hit us in various ways over over two
years and i
mean we all hope it wouldn't be as bad
as being right in the middle of the
first or the second wave but you know
covid is part of the challenge because
you know here we are in august
with the challenges we've got around
ambulance response times waiting to uh
see your gp
um people waiting for operations and
even though we've managed to
get to reduce the number of people
waiting for a long time for
for operations we know that that we have
these enormous challenges even
uh uh even in the middle of august
so we we just have to be kind of
realistic um
about where we are
uh right now and realistic about the
fact that it's going to take some time
for the health service to develop the
capacity it needs to respond to the
challenges
um that we face